on est bien d'accord pendant tout un
week-end bien gardé mais de princesse
attend je les adore et gamines tu sais
mais elles sont sur terre pour me faire
peur et si je perds tu acceptes tu as
prochaine promo appuyé sur la détente et
mois après il ya le vent à prendre en
compte environ 4 noeuds de gauche à
droite
humidité je dirais un bon 60 de
poursuivre pression atmosphérique aussi
avis de tempête comme dans ta petite
culotte
tu les aimes mes petites culottes
c'est bizarre que tu fasses ce genre de
valser bon allez ça va tu la fermes
c'est vraiment eu la ferme c'est surya
les mec à moi ce que tu la fermes ce que
j'en dis ce n'est sa ferme là non le
coup et elle ne l'est pas je retire je
me distrait c'est à mon tour de tirer
non non c'est pas du jeu ça ça comptera
par pêcheur
j'ai offert un karaoké à mes princesses
et elle adore chanter devant strict la
des soeurs entière prend des bouchons
d'oreilles ça peut servir en trois
manches le meilleur gagne alors tu
m'avais pas des projets